[Applaudissements]
en
e
[Musique]
derrière des barreaux
pour quelques mots
qu'il possessif
du
des shows
emily loizeau
souvent sourit pas
et
piqué
quel est ce pays
frappe la nuit
la loi enfin
diego
libre dans sa tête
il venait
solo pect
et
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des chameaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michael gregorio michael non merci
michael
quel et merci merci à tous les musiciens
qui sont avec toi qui ont fait un
travail exceptionnel qui ont répété
toute la journée
michael on a longuement discuté tous les
deux sur cette séquence tu devenir
aujourd'hui en invité finalement tu as
rester en invité parce que je voulais
absolument que tu rêves et je voudrais
vraiment remercier parce que tu nous a
fait vivre un moment exceptionnel
[Musique]